hi in the previous video I talked about
this open letter which has been signed
by a lot of prestigious people which
talks about how there are risks and
possible problems associated with AI and
it says we need to do more thinking
about the future of AI Technologies and
the impact they're going to have on
society but it's worth noting that in
those 8,000 or so signatories there's
quite a broad range of opinions about
the specific nature of these problems uh
which problems are most important what
the time scales are so to say all of
these people are concerned in some sense
with AI safety is not to say that they
all agree with each other and the
document the open letter links to lists
a whole bunch of different things and
I'm going to talk about some of those
now so the first thing is economic
impact things like technological
unemployment you know what if AI puts us
all out of a job or the effects on
economic inequality in the sense that if
the AI Technologies produce a huge
amount of New Wealth not everyone is
going to benefit from that wealth
equally and this can increase inequality
which can cause other problems also some
people are concerned that even even if
we manage to set up a situation where
people don't need to be employed in
order to get the resources that they
need to live there's a question of in a
world in which nobody has to work what
are people actually doing with their
time is it just Leisure how do people
get a feeling of achievement and ideally
they shouldn't just have a feeling of
achievement they should have actual
achievement but it's hard to have actual
achievement in a world in which you're
outperformed in every way by machines
there's concern about AI ethics uh
things like driverless Vehicles this has
been done to death but uh that's just
cuz it's an interesting problem that
we're not sure to deal with yet so you
know you have a self-driving car it's in
some scenario where it has to hit one
person or the other and then the
question is how does it make that
decision um this is a philosophical
question right it's an instance of the
trolley problem in real life so there
are really two questions here the first
is the ethical one how should we design
our AI systems to make ethical decisions
in these situations the interesting
thing to me about this is that humans
are routinely in these situations right
car crashes happen regularly but we
don't have time to make ethical
decisions if you're in this type of
scenario in which which you're forced to
hit someone and you have to choose no
one's going to blame you for choosing
one person or the other because you're
in the middle of a car crash like almost
by definition you have no time to think
whereas with a self-driving car the
decision of how you want your car to
behave needs to be made beforehand with
all the time in the world and no excuses
so what's new isn't the decision itself
so much as it's having enough time to
think also side note prediction I'm
calling it now when self-driving cars
are common we will have a problem with
morons deliberately jumping in front of
them for fun anyway that's one question
the other question is legal uh what
should the law be about this who's
liable the person in the car the person
who owns the car the company that wrote
the software and practically speaking
the way the software actually gets
written will be determined by the legal
question not the ethical one there's
concerns about military use of this
technology um autonomous Weapons Systems
and so on the ethics of that and some
people are worried about discrimination
in machine learning systems that these
systems we build to process people's
data and make decisions about insurance
premiums hiring decisions loans all
kinds of things these systems can be
used for they may end up being racist or
sexist things like that which is another
potential issue there's also privacy
concerns uh people are worry about the
ability of AI systems to deduce private
information from the vast amounts of
public information available to them the
classic example of this is the young
woman who started receiving coupons for
baby food and other baby related stuff
from her supermarket and her father
stormed in there to complain but she
actually was pregnant and the
supermarket's product recommendation
algorithms had noticed that before her
own father I don't even know if that
story is true but it illustrates the
point AI may be able to discover things
about you that you didn't intend to make
public so all of those are problems that
can happen when AI systems are working
more or less as they were intended to
work then you have the stuff that's more
what I've been talking about in earlier
videos which is problems that happen
when AI systems have unexpected
unintended Behavior which is harmful
either during development like in the
stop button problem where I'm talking
about this robot that wants to make you
a cup of tea and ends up running over a
child who's in the in the way that kind
of accident or problems that only happen
once the system is deployed and it
starts behaving in ways that were
unexpected and have negative
consequences this can already be a real
problem with existing machine learning
systems and as those systems get more
powerful and more influential and get
relied on more and more uh those
problems are going to become more and
more important and then you have the
question of general superintelligence
intelligence systems that dramatically
outperform human intelligence across a
wide range of domains that can be a
maximally bad problem so when people say
oh yes I'm concerned about possible
problems with AI they're really talking
about a very wide range of possible
problems here I'm going to go back to
the nuclear analogy I've used in the
past uh imagine if some point around the
turn of the last century a load of
scientists got together and all signed a
letter saying we're concerned about the
risks of nuclear material and so
thousands of people sign this thing and
then it turns out that some of those
people are talking about like radiation
poisoning you know uh Mary cury died
young as a consequence of the radiation
she was exposed to while doing her
research but other people are talking
more about things like the demon core
this plutonium core which caused a lot
of problems during the Manhattan Project
where there were accidents that resulted
in a sudden powerful burst of radiation
which gave acute radiation poisoning to
the scientist conducting the experiment
and anyone who happened to be standing
nearby or you have other people are more
concerned with risks associated with
nuclear power you know you have this
nuclear waste generated that needs to be
disposed of that's a problem or you have
uh the other problem with nuclear power
which is the possibility of meltdowns
which can be disastrous and then you
have other people saying well never mind
all that what about nuclear weapons
right this is the big problem what if
people build nuclear weapons that can
kill millions of people and then if they
proliferate then that can cause vast
problems for Humanity like global
thermonuclear war that's an issue and
then you know beyond that you also have
concerns like okay during the Manhattan
Project there was concern that the
Trinity nuclear test might ignite the
atmosphere the principle of this is
quite similar to the way that a hyd bomb
works you have a standard atom bomb next
to a certain amount of hydrogen and then
uh I'm not a
physicist but more or less the energy
from the fishing reaction the explosion
of the atom bomb kicks off a fusion
reaction in the hydrogen the hydrogen
atoms fuse and give off a tremendous
amount of energy which is another Chain
Reaction it's the same thing that's
happening in the sun right turning
hydrogen into helium but of course in
the sun heavier elements are also fused
up to and including for example nitrogen
so there was some concern when people
were developing the at bomb what if we
Kickstart a fusion chain reaction in
nitrogen because the atmosphere is like
78% nitrogen there's a chance that we
turn the entire atmosphere into a
thermonuclear bomb effectively from the
first time that this issue was raised it
seemed pretty clear that it wasn't going
to happen in the sense that the amount
of energy given off by an atom bomb or a
hydrogen bomb is just not big enough to
do this uh their understanding of
physics at the time pointed to it being
nowhere near enough energy but at the
same time I don't believe they'd ever
actually fused nitrogen in the lab so
they didn't know for sure exactly what
conditions cause nitrogen to fuse and
also they'd never set off a nuclear bomb
before so they didn't know for sure
exactly how much energy they were going
to get out of it so there was a non-zero
probability from their perspective when
they set off the Trinity explosion that
it would end all of humanity
instantaneously more or less right there
and then so before they did it they ran
the numbers again in a few different
ways and they looked at it very
carefully and made very very sure ahead
of time that they were very confident
this wasn't going to be an issue that
they weren't going to ignite the
atmosphere so people have had various
concerns about nuclear material ranging
from oh if you work with it you might
get radiation poisoning to if you screw
it up you may destroy all life on the
planet forever in a giant fiery
explosion and so getting people to sign
a letter that says we're concerned about
nuclear material would cover a broad
range of possibilities so I like a
nuclear analogy here because it helps me
explain something about a paper that I'm
going to go through soon concrete
problems in AI safety because it's
concerned about accidents uh
specifically the paper is looking at
unintended and harmful Behavior
that may emerge from poor design of real
world AI systems and another way that
this is similar to nuclear research is
that the type of knowledge you need in
order to prevent something like the
demon core problem of something going
super critical and dumping out a huge
amount of radiation in your lab is the
same kind of understanding of
radioactivity and file material in
general that you need in order to
understand how nuclear bombs work and
make sure you don't set off one of those
by accident or to understand uh what
storage and transportation technology is
necessary for nuclear weight
or how to prevent meltdowns like a
general good understanding of nuclear
physics will help you with protecting
yourself from getting radiation
poisoning and also hopefully protect you
from accidentally igniting the
atmosphere and I think it's the same in
Ai and I think that's part of what
concrete problems in AI safety is trying
to do it's trying to bring together the
people who are concerned about possibly
igniting the atmosphere the real
apocalyptic super intelligence problems
and the people looking at the more
run-of-the-mill what if my robot ignores
my stop button type problems and it's
trying to point out areas of research
that we could look into that would
actually provide progress on both of
those things where there's overlap
things that we can study that would help
us with current existing AI systems but
that may also help avoiding these huge
global scale super intelligence related
problems problems which like igniting
the atmosphere may or may not at this
point actually turn out to be a real
problem but which are still definitely
worth looking into because these Stakes
are so unbelievably
High
[Music]
I want to end this video with a quick
thank you to my excellent patreon
supporters that's these wonderful people
around here um I'm always looking for
ways to make good use of your support to
improve my videos um I recently built my
own Auto que which I think works really
well uh I've put up a behind the scenes
video on on patreon of how I did that if
you want to check that out but in this
video I especially want to thank Stefan
Skyles or skills who supports me for $20
a month thank you I've actually just
made a new $20 reward level uh you can
go check that out and let me know what
you think thanks again and I'll see you
next time